how's sobriety going i mean like uh you
know they say
no dating within your first year
sobriety are you staying true to that or
you
no man i started dating uh
i started dating my girlfriend in uh
january
so she's been with me through kind of
the uh
the start of this uh the restart i
should say
of the sobriety and man we vibe we vibe
great together
and uh that hasn't been an issue for me
at all
how public have you been about sobriety
like i heard scott asked that question
and i think like whoa whoa whoa like i
don't i don't even know if we won't even
be talking about you've been pretty
public and we can cut it out if you
don't want to no
and dude i've been public about it you
know i i tried you know so
so 18 18 to 25 was uh was pretty heavy
times you know
it was fun it was fun times i i was uh i
was definitely abusing alcohol
and uh got to the point where i had had
enough pain and i needed a break so i
checked into rehab
uh when i was 20 right when i turned 26
i did a 30-day stay and then made it
almost four years
sober and
didn't have a really good program though
didn't have a sponsor
wasn't hitting meetings was just trying
to pretty much white knuckle it
and decided that for you know my 30th
birthday
that you know i wanted to go have fun
phone with my homies saying
and see if i could drink again and i
ended up drinking
and just it just became this like
this crazy thing where it was all i
could think about was drinking and it
wasn't the amount it wasn't
you know getting blacked out or or going
crazy it was just the fact that i could
not get it off my mind and it was one of
those things where it was like
every day was coming around once four
o'clock hit it was like all i could
think about was a drink i was starting
to do
things during the day getting my
business done but i was like almost
doing things
as like trying to get a reward you know
i was trying to do things to be like
okay cool
satisfied i did that now my reward is
this and i wasn't dealing with
a lot of the i wasn't dealing with a lot
of the real feelings the real life
feelings that i needed to be dealing
with
so you know coming into it now
six months so far of 100 sobriety again
with the solid program with sober
friends
doing what i'm supposed to be doing
going through the steps
it's the best thing i've ever done for
sure [ __ ] epic dude
i was fed up with feeling the way i was
feeling and and stop feeling sorry for
myself and actually do something about
it
and get healthy man i i got a lot to
contribute to the world and not only the
skate world just to the world
you know like i i feel i have something
to contribute
whether that's love whether that's
respect you know a solid role model
whatever it may be you know i can help
one person with my story and like
you know sobriety is cool it's cool yeah
you know yeah it is i'm enjoying the
[ __ ] out of it because i got sober right
before i turned 30 and i'm like [ __ ] i
wish i would have done this a lot
earlier i got several 33 33 uh-huh
yeah yeah dude it's pretty rad to jump
on it early man
yeah yeah dude